what's fear factor oh fear fact yeah i
mean a few factors didn't have a lot of
controversy fear factor
i mean i've i've seen it just like yeah
joe rogan did it right because like it's
either like you can eat your own [ __ ] or
drink your own pizza it's not even that
bad though it's like i remember i
remember like i think i saw one episode
or one season where like the
the final gross or whatever the [ __ ] it
was called it was like that the worst
meal
was um it was a bulloot
you know it was it was bullet which is
like the the
the duck fetus that they eat in like
philippines okay and it's like i
remember because when i went to the
philippines for the first time aki was
like do you want to try bullet i'm like
the [ __ ] that it's like it's a duck
fetus it was it was the worst thing they
had on fear factor yeah
and i hate it i'm like people a few
factor are [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're so weird about the fact of being
like i'm like this is delicious what do
you want about it i can just imagine
right someone went to the philippines
right like and then someone really
politely said yo this is our culture
this is what we eat and he's just
licking he's like i can't wait to put
this on for you
people are going to eat this they're so
weird about that it's like i understand
like you know like eating a cockroach or
something right where it's like i think
that shouldn't be eating something that
shouldn't be eaten it isn't really
widely eaten by any culture yeah i kind
of like i get it right like
you know and then there's taking like an
obscure food from like a
cultural background right and it's like
this is disgusting isn't it
look how vile this is someone's gonna
eat this someone's gonna eat this [ __ ]
meanwhile everyone in the philippines is
like
um filipino audience just like microsoft
what like it's either mcdonald's or this
bro we're gonna waste that balloon like
that
oh my god oh no man i'm
thai and thai people eat water bugs and
i i don't stand by that [ __ ]
i still haven't forgotten melin i still
have not forgotten
okay but you're not gonna like go and be
like mom can i take some uh water books
back i'm filming fear factor yeah right
this is crazy nobody eats this
sarah has a choice between jumping off a
bridge or eating a bug
she chose to jump what is what is fifth
[ __ ] i've never watched it yeah
you get two choices no am i crazy uh was
it two choices
it's just a show where it's like
contestants basically line up and being
like
you can eat if you eat this then you go
on to the next round and if you survive
the entire round you get a prize money
or something like that right
but like the the food or what you have
to do is like usually considered
gross according to americans right at
least and like vegetables
i'm gonna get [ __ ]
you know what i mean with that kid who's
just like all a vein popping out it's
like
corner when he has a [ __ ] on america for
30 minutes
hey i think it's fair [ __ ] game i
don't see me [ __ ] emailing americans
being like
stop making british memes i don't say
the word h
shut the [ __ ] up be a little [ __ ] and
take your [ __ ]
we all get mocked okay 21. um but yeah
fairfax
yeah anyway like a carrots
with a [ __ ] celery
celery without hummus
i'm so [ __ ] american i don't actually
believe this i'm joking
this is a joke this is a bit eat the
celery or take the hummus and go home
no but basically it's like it's like you
have to do
something gross or eat something gross
and if you decide to do it then you move
on to the next round if you don't decide
to do it then you get kicked off and
basically
each step it just gets worse and worse
and worse i don't know i might be
talking about
this this is how i remember yeah yeah
and then what's wrong with us one of the
watch people do
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] like this i don't
know
it's entertaining actually i don't know
the flashback to another darren brown
special
okay he did another special as well
which is great where the audience get to
choose whether something bad happened to
the guy or something good happened to
the guy
right there so they would follow a guy
in his daily life yeah yeah
yeah yeah and literally the audience
every single time chose bad things
and like one of them was like almost
like his family gets christmas presents
early
or he gets [ __ ] kidnapped and he
literally got kidnapped because the
audience wanted to see him get kidnapped
we're [ __ ] up we are [ __ ] up do you
know what the most [ __ ] up thing about
that special was
so it so it the special basically ends
right
with you know the audience shows a bad
thing happening like he got kidnapped or
something and then i think as
they were trying to kidnap him um he got
into a car crash now the car crashed
the car crash was staged the audience
didn't know this right
the car crash was stuck and so the
audience seemed get hit by a car
and then it's they just like this
unplanned thing darren brown just walks
off
and then you're just you're just left
seeing like the audience kind of like
what's going on and like one one one of
the audience members going like
uh excuse me you're not being funny but
like
this like it's not our fault yeah hey no
i can't
exactly what she says but she's like
excuse me they're saying this isn't
funny
like can you tell us what's going on
like why would you make him go through
this
and it's it's like the lack of
self-awareness and self-irony that you
literally came on a tv show
and kept voting for bad things to happen
and then something bad thing happened
that wasn't scripted but
because it wasn't scripted suddenly it's
a serious matter right
right yeah it was like really
interesting because it was basically
just like you as the audience does not
care about who is on screen
right you just want to see bad things
happen right you know these are people
it's really good because you know it's
stage well cause it's what you think
right you think it's all fake or like or
you don't care
it was it was a message about like an
anonymity within like
crowds i don't what's the word i'm
looking for like mine yeah the like the
hive mindset right where
if you have anonymity you responsibility
is kind of like taking off you and
you're willing to do like you want to do
things that
you might not do if you know you were
the one responsible i'm pretty sure i
saw like
at least four like black mirror episodes
that were like that
yeah it's yeah i mean the black mirror
sucks now yeah oh my god
it sucks so much i went downhill real
fast yeah yeah yeah